that's what I think it means it means
that I should play with the board
flipped okay this is a first
I'll try it okay so I'm gonna be playing
with the board flipped huh
wow you're really trying to control
everything I do huh
you will not look at the board normally
you said you will look at it from my
perspective as I beat you okay let's
give it a shot here let's see this the
board flipped boom come on black okay
this is different
oh man imagine imagine trying to do a
one-minute chest like this
okay everybody loves the CARICOM whoa
it's just kind of it was glitchy there
for a second it didn't actually didn't
drag the caro-kann is strong
no it's dragging am i able to pre move
yeah it lets me pre move not that that's
illegal oppa that was Joanie a test
so the caro-kann I'm playing on the
black side this is different okay I have
to like rewire myself to think correctly
in this the exchange karo
black is looking pretty good aren't they
ah this is different has anybody done
this before I don't think I've even
never I haven't done this before huh
that's a new way to play a new variant
Fisher random flipped regular chess
flipped okay so
caro-kann exchange this is probably not
a good placement for the knight black is
now getting there light square bishop
out pinning the night if you're playing
the carol you got to get your queen
Bishop out that is the main intention
solve the problem of that
light square Bishop e6 yes II 6 is
strong just get this Bishop out I don't
have to worry about a pin if the bishop
was here I'd definitely go here but
maybe I want to go here instead maybe I
want to reserve my options rook c8 get
on this half open C file I hope I
remember what direction my pawns are
going in its backup I think that that
would be annoying a lot actually some of
the thoughts that I'm experiencing while
playing this game is what what should
black be doing that would be annoying to
why what would i what would I most what
would I like not like to see more than
anything that would have been to move
the bishop hh5 move that's cool all
right I think I just chopped this Knight
wouldn't that be good what can black be
doing I don't know I'm seeing things I'm
gonna take that night yeah I can't this
structure is gonna be pounced on right
right oh man it's really weird it's
really weird okay I'm gonna play my
Bishop to d6 and the reason for it is
because this night is really keeping a
close eye on the h4 square it's Castle
first and I really did I'll often I mess
up when I name squares but I mean it
when I say the h4 square is where this
Knight wants to be because he's gonna be
a monster right here he is definitely
going to be a monster and here he goes
he is on his way to h4 or even f4 you'll
note that when pawns are isolated the
squares in front of them the squares on
the same file as isolated pawns act as
good homes and this Knight is now in
both f4 and h4
is this bishop gonna take the night this
is actually a lot tougher than it may
seem okay if Knight takes I just take
towards the Sun unless I have a good
reason not to and then it could be this
night that maybe jumps in okay maybe I
just go with this right away
yeah let's come here that's got to be
good I would be fearing that if I was
white fear that move fear Knight age
five man my age five looking at that f4
square I want to trade a bunch this
Knight to f4 nothing tricky here maybe a
little bit later on would I try to go
and get a b5 before and that's kind of
tough to do with this Bishop there but
I'm really looking for a bunch of trades
I want to enter a good night well hang
on I take with the knight or the Queen
I don't know how much I don't see any
attack really it's the night and the
queen that I would could only have that
would could maybe give white a problem
but I'm just not seeing that really is
causing white a problem for example I
take with the knight the bishop backs up
having just these two attackers is
really not going to be enough in fact I
see myself if any side I see black is
being the one that can maybe have
pressure with this half open G file so I
want to I want to avoid any any way I
want to avoid any attacks and enter an
endgame where I have a better pawn
structure and a knight that could maybe
camp out on this f4 square that would
take quite a bit of work I'd like to
have maybe my King on f6 pawn on h6 and
the other pawn on d5 and then my knight
sticking around on that square is
probably good and now this is
interesting if I take okay the
structures repaired and I can no longer
rely upon the f4 square so in the
meantime how do I make progress I think
we're at a standstill on the King side
this rook is going to be giving me some
problems soon maybe I should do this
awkward-looking move yeah it's very
awkward looking but why why I want to
get in b5 why didn't I do a 6 first ok
I'm gonna trade I know it repairs that
pawn structure but I didn't do a 6
because I think a good reply would be a
4 and if I ever take away from the
center then the bishop takes my pawn on
a6 this pawn is guarded by my knight so
even if there's doubling it's not a
threat or actually it is doubling the
rooks I have to address this problem
right here right away
because let's say after rook a to G if I
let's say play b4 there's rook to g5
hitting the night and I don't have this
pawn advance to defend my knight anymore
so what I'm getting at is I have to do
this move right
and if my night is being attacked with a
rook move I don't think I move my knight
I think I move my king because if
there's a particular pond break that I
should be fearing I think it's this h4
move okay nothing is done on the Kings
side so let's keep making progress
follow through with this minority attack
there's nothing else going on over here
rip h h4 or g5 i think i throw my king
in the corner and this Knight is still
very strong and was and is within
striking distance and i think i still
keep going are you know what no this a
5mo was probably inaccurate inaccurate
because if I have to move my king where
would I much rather move my king
f8 so that's why I should have done this
move sooner know that I did not consider
okay I want my knight to reinforce this
point let me do this with temple on the
rook my night is done having fun on h5
if rook here I think I just bumped my
king up okay I think I just keep going
now this bishop is unprotected
I think this structure is actually going
to be enough to fend off any potential
sacrifice one piece can be sacrificed
actually two would need to be sacrificed
for my king to really be under any fire
but then that's just leaving a single
piece to attack my king and that's not
going to be enough less than 30 for
white I have broken through on the Queen
side my rooks are very active I can't
get really more active than this with my
rook lateral and along a file and I
could grab this pawn with check I don't
see a reason not to do that the rook is
threatening my rook and I pretty much
have to take so let's do that and now I
where would my knight like to be
probably back here I'm f4
right there 20 seconds for Team white
let's pin this bish up and if King here
I thought okay I was gonna say if King
here I could still go to this square but
now I could go there and just pick up
that piece it's gonna be game over and
if that looked simple it was not that
was really a tough adjustment playing
with the board flipped could gain that
was different
interesting idea there mister go fishing
to suggest a flipped board while I play
alright so let's see how things were for
you don't obstruct your C pond that's
one thing
don't don't ya don't do that definitely
don't do that also your dark square
Bishop two reasons not to go here well
it's just watching over a pond you don't
need to I maybe I can get more than two
reasons you're watching over a pond you
don't need to another one is there's
more aggressive squares f4 and g5 g5v
pending my night and a third one notice
that this is a half open file and once
Castle your rook would left and play to
e1 and not have any pieces in its way
that not have any pieces kind of masking
it from seeing the black side if your
bishops on e3 and you have your rook on
the one your bishop is putting a
blindfold over that Bishop your yeah
your bishop is putting a blindfold over
that rook forget what I just said right
there okay those are my main suggestions
this I don't know that you can really
deal with that I don't know that you
could allow that compromise King side
structure to occur you might have to
actually just pull the bishop back and
then free your knight up in that way
g4 I'm assuming you didn't do because
it's just very weakening I can see why
you would not want to do that maybe it's
best to bring that bishop back and then
your knight is able to move things
become very tough now structurally
things are good I think in this ending
right here right here okay let me back
up I think at this point after I play
rook b8 don't play rook g4 make me work
a little bit harder to get this advance
in play a4 here I think that that's an
improvement slow this down a little bit
a4 you can't translate as follows a
four-bit was basically saying you know
what if black is to get in b5
successfully your rook on a1 will at
least get to play along the a file so
get him working first get your pawn up
to a four now it's going to be tough I
don't know that there's a good solution
my rooks get very active and I'm there
to secure my one point these rooks are
also kind of out of play if there's not
an attack against my King and they're
just you know they're they're out of
planes were beyond the point of where
it's recoverable so all right a good
game to go fishing